قبل الخوض في تفاصيل العمليات
اليوميه كيف يمكن للجنود ان يقاتلوا في
الميدان بينما قيادات الجيش الكبيره رئيس
الاركان يواجهوا حربا شرسه من قبل
القيادات السياسيه واعضاء الحكومه ما مدى
الاثر النفسي الذي يقع على الجنود في مثل
هذه
الظروف يعني بالتاكيد اذا ما عرفنا كيف
يعني ترسم الخطط العسكريه يجب ان نع ان
المستوى السياسي يحدد الهدف السياسي
ويحوله الى المستوى العسكري المستوى
العسكري يقرا تقدير الموقف التعبوي ويضعه
وهناك يعني معلومات تفصيليه تعتمد على ما
هو الهدف السياسي الذي يعني طلب من
المستوى السياسي العسك العسكري ينتظر من
السياسي فبالتالي اذا ما كان هناك خلاف
هذا يعني ان المستوى السياسي لم يعطي
المستوى العسكري الهدف السياسي او ربما
اعطاه الهدف السياسي الذي يتهمه العسكري
فيه الان يعني المستوى العسكري الان واقصد
هنا وزير الحرب جلنت ورئيس هيئه الاركان
هاليفي يتهمون نتنياهو بانه حدد لهم هدفين
يعني صعبين المنال وهو القضاء على
المقاومه الفلسطينيه
و تحرير الاسرى بالقوه العسكريه و وهنا
بدا الخلاف وهنا بدات الخطط العسكريه تفشل
في الميدان لانه يعني ما ما نشاهده على
ارض الواقع بعد مرور ثلاثه اشهر يعني نعرف
تماما ان الخطط العسكريه ممكن ان تعدل
وتبدل تبعا للوقائع الميدانيه اما ان تعدل
الاهداف ولم تحقق الاهداف الاصليه او يضاف
عليها اهداف جديده هذا بالتاكيد يعني
انعكاس لواقع الخلاف ما بين المستوى
السياسي والمستوى العسكري لانه المستوى
السياسي اراد ان يحمل المسؤوليه للعسكري
العسكري يعرف تماما قدرات الجيش
الاسرائيلي وخاصه ان بعد مرور ثلاثه اشهر
وهم غير قادرين على تحقيق اي هدف من
الاهداف التي ذك اثر ذلك على الميدان
اذا اكيد هذا انعكس على الميدان فشل يعني
حينما حينما يتحدث قاده الا القاده
الاسرائيليون العسكريون لانهم يحتاجون الى
الوصول الى خانيونس اي الى اطراف خانيونس
لمده شهر والى دخول قان يونس عده اشهر هذا
اعتراف بالفشل اعتراف بانهم فشلوا وخاصه
ان العقيده العسكريه القتاليه تعتمد دائما
وابدا على الحروب الخاطفه وهذا كان في
مواجهه جيوش وليس في مواجهه مقاومه محاصره
امكان بزيدك من الشعر بيتن سياده اللواء
ان المتحدث العسكري هجار يقول ان اداء
القوات المسلحه واداء الجيش سيكون اكثر
كفاءه خلال عام 2024 كانه يقول انها لم
تكن ب هذا القدر من الكفاءه خلال الشهور
الثلاثه الماضيه صبت هذا صحيح هذا اعتراف
مباشر بان الكفاءه ستاتي في عام 2024 وهو
لا يعرف ان هذه الكفاءه ستقل كما قلت عند
اللواء الجولاني الذي ذهب الى الشجاعيه
ليصفي حسابه مع الشجاعيه وال وال الشجاعيه
صفت حسابها معه وهزم شر هزيمه وكلنا شاهد
هذا اللواء الجولاني نخبه النخبه كيف رقص
فرحا حينما حينما غادر الشج يه وهو لم
يحقق اهدافه وهذا معيب في الجيوش ان ترقص
وان تفرح وانت لم تحقق اهدافك وهذا طبعا
ينعكس اخي العزيز على على معنويات الجنود
الاسرائيليين بالمجمل في في في داخل قطاع
غزه يعني واضح ان حالات الصدمه حالات
الاعاقه الخسائر الكفاءه القتاليه
المتدنيه الروح المعنويه المنخفضه عند
الجيش الاسرائيلي كلها نتيجه ان هناك
مقاومه فلسطينيه باسله استطاعت ان تدخل
الرعب
في قلوب وعقول الاسرائيليين قبل ان تعلمهم
فنون القتال معروف انه القتال في المدن
هذا يحتاج الى شجاعه الى بساله الى فن فن
قتال يتقنه المقاتلين الجيش الاسرائيلي
يحاول ان يقلد المقاومين حاول اكثر من مره
حينما حاول ان يدخل الى بعض الاحياء ولكنه
انسحب واستعان بسلاح الجو بسلاح المدفعيه
ونحن نراقب ونتابع عن كثب ونشعر بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي حتى الان لم يستغني لا عن
المدفع ولا عن الدبابه وعن الطائره وهذا
يعني انه لا يمكن لهذا الجيش الذي يعتمد
على السلاح البعيد ان يحقق انجازات على
الارض لانه معروف السلاح لا يقاتل الذي
يقاتل هو من يحمل السلاح ومن يحمل السلاح
ضعيف وكفاءاته القتاليه متدنيه وروحه
المعنويه منخفضه فلذلك لن يحقق اهدافه
مهما طال الوقت